hi Michael how are you pretty good nice
to see ya man right on
welcome to the show we were just talking
about the witch named Dolores what
Claiborne from the cranberries and the
cranberries what I mean she passed away
the lead singer the cranberries I didn't
what the really get our whoa no I didn't
know personally but I knew her music
yesterday she's 46 that's really young
yeah and she she passed away they don't
know they haven't announced the cause or
anything but they're saying it's not
suspicious and I don't know I don't know
if she was sick or anything but it could
have been suicide they don't know sorry
well I mean that's kind of funny like
it's either one or the other right you
think yeah I see I see there were
accidental roots not sure she was found
dead in her hotel room and Jim theorized
it could have been a car I didn't know I
forgot the hotel right who knew could be
suicide it could be a heart attack or
could be a car wreck and they pointed
out there was a hotel room that's too
many options remove the carpet I've been
an insect bite yeah yeah so here in
abandoned I was I was I mean for a while
I you know I was in this band called
Nico Vega and before that the wells and
you know we did some touring and stuff
and which I loved and I thought I was
gonna I thought I was basically gonna be
in a band for the rest of my life which
wouldn't have been a bad game what'd you
do I was a drummer okay yeah so I mean
but it's cuz I was getting all these
like gangster parts you know and acting
and basically I was working like a month
out of the year so I was like you know
you know and I was doing music the rest
of the year so I was like yeah I'm just
gonna do that so what point were you
like oh I'm gonna do this music thing
anymore well here's the thing I did you
know I I worked on this movie crash
right working on it for four days right
right didn't think you only in that for
all four I was a 40-day I'm like I made
like no money that's one of my favorite
films of all time
do you think what everybody's favorite
things ever is right that's awesome man
that's cool um so I did that movie for
four days I was in it for four days and
I was like oh this is really cool man I
loved it it's one of the first times
that I actually got to do some good
writing and then I didn't think anything
of it and then you know I was doing
music music music we got offers from you
know a couple little labels but it
wasn't a big deal and then you know
there was a premiere and then I took the
band of the premiere and the lead singer
age of Oakland says you're gonna you're
gonna
I was like no way because I hardly
worked you know I worked literally five
weeks four weeks out of the year and
like here in their nests they know this
five week child yeah is like and I was
born eight over here
gangster from New York yeah gangster
from LA all the all the different
accents gangs from Chicago so like it
wasn't you know I didn't think anything
when there's gonna come of it to be
honest
and you did crash was obviously Paul
Haggis directed now there's all this
stuff happening with him and what was
your relationship like with him I mean
again four days is hard to say but you
also did Million Dollar Baby
yeah I mean it was great man I'm like
him and Bobby Moresco actually directed
the movie and it was really cool like he
was you know I'm like I thanked him for
like he wrote a great great part and
then he wrote an amazing monologue so I
was like really thankful so indeed ever
so you're saying but after crash is when
everything changed like people started
because obviously that won Best Picture
and it became the movie that year and is
that when people started being like oh
he's not just the guy doing bit gangster
parts Michael Pena is a guy who we can
count on to do other stuff other gangs
because I actually played a gangster in
that movie as well but it was an axe
caster right you know enough yeah you
know crazy I'm like man it was like
you're taking me back it was literally
like a crazy dream that one year because
I'm like I lived in a shoe box I mean my
apartment was smaller than this you know
was pointing in this tiny apartment and
then no yeah so and then you know I I
got to meet Oliver Stone and when you're
you know I love movies man I just love
them like and you know my family we used
to go every Sunday and that was the
thing spending a dollar 25 on like you
know Latin movies or Spanish movies I
meant and then you know they would have
the one English movie you know like to
feel the dreams or something cool like
that you know and so that was a dream of
mine and then I met Oliver Stone and
Oliver Stone is you know wants to meet
you for a movie and I was like oh for
what is it and I
descriptives for World Trade Center and
it was like it was like will Jimeno and
I mcLaughlin and that was like one of
the two leads I was like for what part
four will Jimeno I I was it changed my
life I was speechless obviously and then
I met him and you know we had a good
meeting and then you know I got the
offer and I was just you know I remember
sitting at home and not knowing what to
think how much pressure is in one of
those meetings it's a meeting it's not
an audition where it's like you can
practice the part they just want to get
to know you so like how do you how do
you prepare like what's your strategy
going in there be honest with you there
was no pressure no pressure because I
thought there's no way in the world I'm
gonna get this part I see yeah so I was
I think it's just a cool bit a chance to
meet Oliver Stone I've seen every one of
his movies yeah I studied that guy and
I'm like it and and you know there's a
certain point you think I'm not even
gonna study this guy because I'm like I
you know it's he's too far advanced he's
too much of a great director for me to
even let me just enjoy it and then I but
but I did say I'm like how did you use
his actors oh that's cool that's really
cool that's really cool so I met a more
as a fan and didn't anything and I just
got like you know a free interview it
seemed like it was the depart was way
too big it'll never happen so just enjoy
it
yeah exactly I'm like you know you're
gonna give it to somebody who's like
whatever another film you should have
won an Oscar for it's one of my favorite
comedies ever with Seth Rogen observably
so great I can never stop [ __ ] funny
that movie was cute was so mean Ray
Liotta was great in that I hate your
guts that guy but his ease Ansari was
really funny in that as much right as
yeah yeah you know what he spread the
lotion on man he was so funny putting
fingers in the girl's mouth oh yeah I
forgot he was in he had that big scene
with Seth they're going [ __ ] you is it
over [ __ ] what would they say in back I
don't know you could say that ah yeah
that's what they're doing right yeah
oh no but I do know you'd say that on
radio sure you said sure with pride well
our channels uncensored you can say what
you want we worked very very hard on
making sure we can say [ __ ] you all day
if we want to I just so weird for me for
me in the
radio environment but yeah it's some
cool movies man you've been in some
really really great films I was gonna
like so you get there right and like you
find out you get this part from Oliver
snow and you're like I don't I don't
even know what's going on you're still
on this like weird dream of like I don't
know what's happening what's it like to
work with him once you get on so well I
mean I once they said once they said
that I got the part and you know I
started rehearsing I'm not gonna lie I
was I was nervous that's when the nerves
kicked in man I was so nervous I
couldn't even look anybody in the eye I
was like I must have looked like some
kind of crackhead I said away from
coffee I you know I was freaking out and
I was still really nervous the first two
three weeks of filming and plus you got
to understand like in crash I'm like it
was only three scenes right I only
really did three scenes that was my
biggest part to date you know and I was
really good at saying like oh he's over
there or you know just one-liners here
and there's like rot that he's like I am
sir or you know getting arrested or
whatever on so it was like the first
time that I had a lot of dialogue as
well like I'm in a lot of scenes so I'm
like it was a it was a huge gradient to
jump what was the first scene you shot
oh man that's a good question well do
you remember the first the first take
you [ __ ] up like with Oliver Stone
Nicola I didn't I done what I did is I
rehearsed for weeks and weeks
okay and weeks and made sure that I that
I thought I was doing it kind of like a
play cuz it's a you know you feel like
it's your big shot sure I might ladies
I'm like almost shaking now just
thinking about it and they can replace
you right like all right and and they
can replace you very quickly so even
when you get the role in your head like
you're all nerve doubt so there's
nothing in any movie because if you
think about it like you know after a
week you know we're shooting for 12
weeks and it's a 60 million dollar
budget right you know and and some of it
is based on this new kid and they can
just whenever they want pull the plug
and say you know what we're just gonna
shoot his coverage you know his side of
it on the camera and just like let him
be gone you know what just happened a
lot if they can replace Harvey Keitel in
in Apocalypse Now where he would he
really had the lead before before Martin
Sheen got it that was Harvey Keitel but
did they film anything oh yeah and I
don't know how long they shot for but
it's like Eric Stoltz in the future
Eric Stults they can say sometimes we'll
go let's cut our losses and just go back
and redo it yeah because they're
thinking of like and they're protecting
their investment you know what I mean
and and half of the investment is in
post-production it's getting them the
right music it's you know editing it you
know whatever and so they you know they
gotta take care of the money so the
table read you read through the whole
thing I was on a series for two seasons
recently called power I didn't go to one
table read doing this no because I'm
like they're gonna fire me in the table
I was legitimately busy but like I had
like other stuff that would let me know
like I had stopped waiting for the wink
I was like legitimately busy no no I did
have but I probably could have moved
some of it but I'm like [ __ ] that I'm
not giving these guys a chance to fire I
just knew they were gonna fire me if I
said right right you get that that's
what's weird man and I still get it like
with every freaking movie and like man
like it's I feel blessed you know what I
mean to be able to keep my jobs so have
you gotten but have you gotten
comfortable to a point yet where you
know like feel you so you don't know
like the the big parts are like I'm I
feel like they could take it away at any
time yeah like at any time you know it
could be over cuz it seems like every
time you get one like you hit it out of
the park like end of watch was amazing
too
well you know what I that's where crash
really really helped me out it was like
I you know they I don't know for some
reason it's kind of like a club or
whatever like oh he's good in this and
it's a good movie and it won the Oscar
which is a blessing and then they you
know you you kind of get better writing
right and then so I remember reading end
of watch and I gotta be honest with you
I didn't understand the story but I
really wanted to be in this movie I
don't even know how much I got paid for
it you know and those are the best
movies for me what I'm like I don't care
how much the pay is I'm like I just
would love to be in this movie you know
I got a nine-year-old kid I'm just
thinking I just want him to be proud of
me I'm proud of me right you wanted to
be able to look at your work and be
largest I mean just be proud of your own
work yeah I know what I mean so that's
but when you read a great script and and
you're just there dumbfounded with how
great it is then you just want to be in
that movie at some point you are I guess
you get to the point where like you
don't want your kid to be like yeah my
dad's an actor he's like this gangster
over here in the corner this movie
but there is that when he sees my
earlier work he's like yeah that's him
behind the only other guy who is the guy
who is the guy would always play guy he
was in blood in blood out he's been in a
million he played he was I think it's a
Mexican he played that he always played
a gangster he's in the same role Danny
Trejo
no no not any another guy we look at
blood blood in blood out the the he's a
Latin actor I think he passed away no as
soon as you see him he's in everything
oh my god that guy and he almost always
played a gangster you know what's funny
I don't know what Roy's been googling
but he put blood in blood out you know
and in the autocomplete it said blood in
and he was stool you know what
surprising some of these guys that
always play gangsters and that's why I
feel blessed and I feel lucky I don't
know if it was blood and blood out or
maybe it was a note of color sorry
colors you color colored not blood in
blood call the colors some of these guys
like went to Juilliard and Benjamin
Bratt did like Persian brat yeah or like
the guy in what's-his-name god I can't
believe he's actually a buddy of mine he
was an end of watch well maybe not that
one maybe not that one but Don chelli
was in colors that was Don cheated on
Tito yeah Wow and the [ __ ] front left
that he's playing against Yellin all
strikes me is like a pretty intense G
great man I mean I don't know I'm aside
from watching him in movies but he seems
like he completely like falls into these
roles especially like you know as time
has gone on it seems like he for a
second could have gone the route of
heartthrob guy and decided to
specifically go in a different direction
he's marley intense he's too smart yes
like a really intellectual guy but like
he you know he really cares about the
movie i got a you know he he was just
instrumental in me and an end of watch
because it was again went you know that
was another I haven't had a you know a
co-starring part in a while or whatever
because I'm like I did something what
the writers strike you know I was doing
these kind of movies and then writers
strike and then it a movie stopped being
made so I'm like you know for two
years to three years I had to start over
again it felt like and then Wow and he
was really awesome about it he's like
dude if there's a scene you know that
like just chew it up man just chew it up
it's your scene and how many lead actors
do that yeah there's not a lot I have to
be honest there's been times we've been
Pulis odd and you're like can you can
you really can you tone it down a bit
you know this is his scene yeah you got
embarrassing when they do that no you
understand you understand cuz it's a you
know they they have to carry the movie
sure right and then I for me that the
the attitude of the supporting actor is
that you have to affect the the the lead
actor you know what I mean so that they
they just react they're reacting they're
reacting all you have to do enough to
make them react the way they need to
read yeah they need to react and not
overdo it it's just amazing because like
it just seems like such a trip because
obviously being in movies is like a huge
ego boost right like when people know
you as this guy from a movie that would
do things like it would do things to my
ego but you have to maintain like a huge
degree of humility to survive being on a
movie set because you have to understand
stuff like that like yeah he comes up to
you not take that personally a lunch as
a lunch it doesn't mean you're getting
the role right you know what I mean no
yeah man I took my eyes I mean I I
struggled for 17 years and then it's
been happening for you know the last
five six years or something like that so
I count my blessings because I make
there's buddies of mine they've been
that I've been you know going auditions
with for years and years and years and
they never got the break and and they're
you know I just as good if not better
right or whatever and for some reason
you know the you know it just rolled
away it did and so you can't help but be
humble but also like you see the people
that are not and they they're bored with
acting and they don't like acting and
you're like I don't want to be one of
those guys you know if I if at one point
I just don't like acting and don't have
the passion for it then I just leave
into something and start drumming again
I still got a CNC drum kit and it's it's
being delivered to my house this week I
can't wait you don't to [ __ ] up your
shoulders your drummer always have these
weird injuries so I guess my life
because it's I do cross handed right
like traditional like that right
but for me I'm like I just I'll just sit
20 minutes like the way to armor the way
drummer is the traditional holding the
stick to a jazz drummers do it
which I guess is called cross hand which
is like one upside down and one tap it's
the most uncomfortable looking thing
I've ever seen you know just and then
keep doing other things
that's all for nation yes I have a
question for you too about season four
of my one of my favorite shows oh yeah
yeah yeah rockers the best thing on
Netflix the ended season 3 and it looks
like now he's going to what's the Leeds
name of your Pablo a power no no you
clearly doctor uh it's peskow Pascal
yeah yeah yeah
Pascal Pascal Pedro Pablo is it yeah I
believe so I think it's Pedro Brisco or
whatever it might be right
god dammit I wrong Pedro Pascal I do but
I I knew there was a P in it now it's
supposed to take place in Mexico a
season four I don't know what are you
allowed to say about it I dude I can't
say anything okay can I say this are you
done shooting no I'm you see the hair
yeah that's so calm I god I'm not used
to having let me look at the hair and
figure out who he's playing now in the
SDK there was a problem Netflix there
their location scout was killed in
Mexico yeah while he was looking for a
now again I don't know if they've ever
established why it could have been wrong
place wrong time maybe he was up to
something or maybe it was just he didn't
that's right permission to go in so let
me ask you wherever they decided to
shoot were you nervous being in any
locations well I mean look just you know
form our conversation before I'm nervous
anyway I mean like it's there's a lot of
pressure when you're you know you're
reading your lines by yourself like in
you know in the hotel and like making
trying to make sure like you do some
that you're okay and then there's like a
hundred people see what you were
planning on so that's nerve-racking and
then there's you know I did a movie
before it's called Chavez Cesar Chavez
in in Mexico and it's not as bad as they
say you know what I mean it's like you
know we're in Mexico to shoot a demo CEO
it's called most
Oh Senora and there's there is some you
know some cartel activity there but the
thing is is that unlike unless you're
involved with or against the cartels
they don't they don't mess with you like
they wouldn't want to kill the customer
no but they're more with kidnapping they
do a lot of kidnapping yeah that's on a
whole nother level and that's what you
get security did you have security with
you do you have security how many how
many guys you have with you three three
guys okay well guys driver and security
and then like the quote-unquote
assistant was able to also the guy that
will tell me what time it is to pray for
lunch and he has an m16 oh yeah that's
scary though I mean especially it is
scary but you know I it's kind of thing
where I've been doing it for 22 years
now and my first film was like you know
I was in Asheville North Carolina I was
the only Mexican dude there so there's a
fear there sure sure and then you know I
was in Serbia like you know last year
would you shoot their distinct this
movie called extinction for universal um
and so you travel you know what I mean
it's just a way of life I guess but it's
we have to figure they do I don't we
talk to a guy Jeff Ross a comedian who
did a shoot down at funny man very fun
it's fine
and he's ballsy because Jeff will do
comedy anywhere and he said that their
greatest comedy apparent yes where he's
[ __ ] on people yes and I think that
he was in Juarez and I imagine there's
not as other roasts yeah that's okay
there's a place within the all these
places you kind of have to clear it with
the cartel that you're gonna be there
because the cartel is even more powerful
than the police and you have to let the
cartel know you're gonna be there so
whoever you were we're not shooting they
may have that with with people on that
side it's amazing uh
you're freaking me out now man yeah oh
yeah cuz you got to go back go back
that's right so at least we know he's in
Mexico yeah that's cool no I got to tell
you I'm like I I read the scripts and
I'm just excited about this as I am with
like you know something like a end of
watch or a crash you are really really
good writing
I mean I'm amazed like Eric Newman in
the gang like they they you know they
they really pride themselves and and
these scripts and they take that a lot
of time they're not just like running on
auto are you good guy or bad guy
I can't tell you yeah okay um I got long
hair though yeah long hair makes me
believe
I mean it could be a car might be yeah
he might be an undercover see the
problem is like if this were you years
ago we'd know you'd be typecast you'd be
a good gas or a drug deal or something
but now you do cop or gangster or rug
dealer like you've done all that exactly
so I don't know I don't know but I feel
like it is the hair is more like a drug
a guy who's made money in crime he's not
playing el chapo not chopped off he's
good and you don't have the right face
for a chap unless they really made you a
Mexican face now el Chapo's chubbier and
not I say that with all due respect yeah
but the camera adds I mean don't mess
with my time my casting here man that's
a that's a great point
by the way they have a series on Netflix
called El Chapo as good as narcos but it
is really good and the guy who plays him
there's a [ __ ] great job yeah there's
other days are there like spin-offs I
think I've seen that one as well
that they use that model but you know
with the you know some of the fond
footage or what and the real footage of
it yeah the real footage I mean it's
it's it's a it's a great model and then
you know narcos is the one that made
that up where they let you know I've
never seen anyone do it besides narcos
and and I love that they would do that
like in season 1 the guys name I'm
saying it wrong I think lalu ego mez
played him a gotcha be a porn star in
[ __ ] Boogie Nights oh yeah dialogue
hey baby where are you going awful great
everything's great in everything you
guys [ __ ] Q&A with Nick Nolte do you
see that no come on oh it's great
Timothy Hutton Zinn it Nick Nolte plays
a [ __ ] a corrupt
Irish cop who's attracted to
transsexuals what cop after my own heart
yeah yeah this season one who ever play
their show like the real footage of guys
yeah getting caught and you can see
they're different than the actors and
that didn't hurt the show at all
yeah he strengthened the front would
like yeah I mean like as long as you
Spanish and you have the you know the
the willingness to speak Spanish because
Guzman isn't like Puerto Rican or
something I don't know
yeah he was in Colombia kpop you know do
nothing and it was still awesome yeah
most people can't like I can't tell the
difference between a lot of acts
and like a lot of people can't tell the
difference in American accents they just
know American well I don't know man can
they cuz I'm like a south I feel like
yeah I feel like the New York South and
then like middle America and then
there's you know the the West Coast like
do you think most people who are not
from here can tell that maybe they can
and I guess I think they can because of
the movies I mean cuz I mean that's one
of our biggest exports as movies right
you know that's why like in England or
whatever like they can speak they can do
our accent because they grow up watch it
and like most of the movies are made my
Hollywood bike yeah like American
speaking people yeah so they try and
accent and they they have even a better
American accent than Americans do yeah
I'm amazed when you see people at the
wire is probably my favorite show half
of them are British yeah right
every time I feel like probably over
half of the people that I've interviewed
about that show they come in here in the
British accent are you not you too yeah
a dress Elba the guy who played the
mayor Domenic West what's the population
of England I just put it on 39 million
39 I'm guessing I could be wrong we have
like 400 million people and like all the
English people are taking fifty three I
was joking I mean what six times bigger
and they're I mean they're like half a
Hollywood that's 2011 yeah I'm tired of
them I think do do theater as well
usually I did man I'm like I gotta be
honest with you I started acting you
know just to make some money cuz I bro
up or yeah and so like I you know I
would you grow up I grew up with Chicago
I grew up like across the street from
Douglas Park work is that bad is bad I
had my first bike for 30 minutes how do
you take it my it was a huffy and it
cost $100 man which was crazy sure
effort and my dad built it and put it
together and I was like oh yes and you
know we weren't row across the street
with my with my cousin I don't know if
it was for Christmas or not but anyway
riding a bike I just feel a big punch in
my chest and I'm ten years old man sure
and it was like some grown men just like
punch me in the chest and took my bike
and I remember that they couldn't even
put their you know their legs on the
pedal and walk bike yeah and they just
went off and then my cousin was like
yeah let's go
was a gas slow down dude that's like for
dad say it just felt that bike oh he was
mad yeah it was mad because if you think
about it he probably made like $250 a
week right
so that's $100 that's half your your
sounds almost half a salary
yeah he was really bummed really upset
but we wouldn't know where to go you
know we went through like you know
they're not gonna have it out and I
didn't have my name on it
yeah and did you have any and we want to
discuss Michael's movie too just did you
see any violence growing up you must
have it and for that to happen 30
minutes after your first bike was there
a temptation you might get into a gang
at that it's Chicago cuz you know what
to be honest with you man I was like we
grew up in church you know I'm Christian
I'm still Christian you know what I mean
so I'm like I I I don't know man
something about my parents just like and
also I didn't like taking orders from
somebody for their benefit you know
everything which is a I don't know and I
could see though like it's it's it's
tough man it's it's not as easy as you
think to not be in gangs right because
it's a family especially if you don't
have a dad or you know parents and then
like or parents that are there you know
I grew up in a loving family we were
broke but when like it was a loving
family if you're not there and they're
like you're kind of a family it's it's
tough for someone who does only take you
orders you picked a weird profession
what's it like working with Mike working
with Michael Shannon he's like one of my
favorite people to watch renewed he's
legit he's legit yeah I and and you know
what funny story like I did a movie with
him 22 years ago my first movie that I
didn't get yeah my first movie that I
didn't get yeah yeah cuz I was an extra
and he was playing some kid he had long
hair man and he sat to my right and and
he was so good you know I was amazed
even at 19 I was like wow this was
pretty amazing he got fired
Wow and I was like what'd he get fired I
was like he's like who's that I asked
one of the producers like yeah it says
that the weird kid he got fired is that
he was too weird
so I know I thought it was awesome and
your movies called 12 strong yeah it's
about a bunch of the special forces that
were the first ones as they say with
boots on the ground in Afghanistan after
9/11 what branch of the military I went
over there in 2003 and perform for guys
that had been there they first hit
Afghanistan in October of 2001 like they
were there less than
month after 9/11 are these like what who
are the guys you're portraying are they
Green Berets or what other Green Berets
and by the way what did you what did you
perform comment I just did stand-up yeah
that's and one of the place that we went
to was this place they said these guys
never get visitors and they showed us
Saddam's private stock of guns like his
gold guns was a tractor trailer thing
full of all his actual weapons when he
was before the cartels started doing
that oh yeah yeah he had a he had a lot
of lovely weapons and they said that
like one of the guys spoke Farsi and one
of the guys did they were all like Deep
Cover guys that weren't even they
weren't there fighting they were they
are kind of blending it yeah yeah so
it's weird man these guys like it's
twelve guys it's it's it's bad well when
I read the logline I was like wow this
is a really interesting story I'd like
I'd love to I'd love to see where it
goes and then I read the script and it's
based on a true story and I couldn't
believe it it's like basically it's it's
a whole new tactic where you put 12 guys
on the on some mountain you know and
they had like these range finders where
they had to get close enough to you know
point the rangefinders at this thing and
then call in an airstrike and they had
to take over this city which was like
the training ground for these terrorists
and you know these terrorists like we
obviously we knew what they could what
they were capable of in you know per 911
so it was their job to take over the
city and so they you know they get along
willings warlords and you know they get
on horseback and none of these guys can
ride except one guy I mean of course
that's Chris Hemsworth his character and
then uh yeah and then they did go in and
take over the city and it's crazy man
when you when you meet I'm sure like how
you met these Green Berets like it takes
a special kind of person to do that kind
of you know the kind of job somebody who
can overcome their fear that way you
know other the warlord you meet is he
guy that you're with does he know what
you're there for yeah I mean like the
CIA goes in first they get all the
intelligence they briefed the guys they
get the right guys you know and there I
did some some of the guys don't even
have weapons and they're you know going
around it takes a special kind of person
to be that guy to just to get Intel but
that yeah we know in forces and you know
it's kind of cool to like just to know
as an American that there's people out
there that they're not all terrorists
right you know there's a lot of good the
majority are actually good people I
think that Sam disagrees but I actually
believe that
that's not the case disagree he's not
he's not speaking of me inaccurately you
know how they would get Intel from some
of these guys to it I'm off the middle
shows this no gifts gifts viagra they
would give a lot of these old warlords
viagra and they couldn't believe that it
enabled kid on them have like a bunch of
wives and now these older guys were able
to have sex with a lot of the women who
they were married to viagra they thought
was much miracle that's to the chagrin
of the women or maybe not know but
here's the thing though like how do you
introduce this like they take this pill
that would surround them would buy a
bunch of guys but there was a bunch of
wives to the brown wire the fighting
area no no but the warlords in the
villages they not approve did they work
they work as I take this and he's like
oh this is really hey this will help you
have sex with your wife we'd like some
information have this one on us then
come back you'll tell us we want to know